[Music]
you ready for this election to be over
huh yeah
man i can't it's getting crazy do you
hear what donald trump did ladies and
gentlemen donald trump is trying to
spoil the election for president obama
at the last minute
he's got he's got a new stunt this is
true today donald trump said he'd give
five million dollars to charity if
president obama releases his college
records
yeah
obama responded by sending trump a full
transcript from his alma mater the
university of shove it up your ass
that's true
that's a true story
[Music]
which i was shocked to find out is an
accredited university a really good
school they have an excellent hockey
team yeah
great humanities department good
what the hell is trump doing he always
comes up with a way to make it about him
well he's no he says it's not about him
it's about the united states of america
that's my trump i haven't done it in a
while
[Applause]
trump has been sucking on a lemon
and he's been in a wind tunnel
well this is interesting i got some news
worldwide
globally
oh is this still look stupid
it's not good thank you ma'am help me
out here straighten it out get your
hands in there and straighten it out
[Applause]
oh hello
thank you very much
that was fantastic
all right uh i'm distracted now uh
no this is true globally people tend to
prefer obama apparently
yeah people listen to this
people surveyed in 21 countries
overwhelmingly favor president obama
over mitt romney
yeah
hello
although romney is still a huge favorite
in the country of kakistan
[Laughter]
a new article on mitt romney says that
he frequently uses the word gosh
yeah yeah but only when he's talking to
his youngest son gosh romney
[Laughter]
why is that name sillier than any of the
other names i don't know
speaking of romney sons after the debate
on monday
mitt romney's son tag
that's real that's a real name
god is conan do it
now after the debate on monday mitt
romney's son tag apologized to president
obama for saying he wanted to punch him
not yeah
then obama's daughter sasha apologized
to tag for saying his father's proposed
cap on itemized deductions cannot raise
enough revenue to compensate for
revenues lost by his plans to cut income
tax rates
[Applause]
yeah
then she kicked him in the balls uh
that's
true
last night i mean i don't think anybody
saw this debate last night last night
was the debate among third-party
presidential candidates and each
candidate each one came out in favor of
medical marijuana
that was the
first presidential debate to air on the
cartoon network
people loved it
remember herman cain herman cain's
former mistress says she's writing a
tell-all about her time with the former
presidential candidate
yeah the book is called no one cares
and i got some bad news for the gaming
industry i don't know if we have any
people to play games here but the
company that makes the game farmville
announced it's laying off 160 employees
yeah or to put it another way 160 people
are about to spend a lot more time on
farmville
it's true
[Applause]
a website the reaction to people losing
their jobs at farmville decimated this
crowd yeah yeah
nothing else i'd brought up so far
you know but then you bring up farmville
is not doing well crowd just like oh no
[Laughter]
a website has posted several photos of
retired playboy bunnies who are now in
their 60s
yeah to see their entire breast you just
need to keep scrolling down
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that was for good luck yeah